[Music]
introduce you to your next guest who
hasn't been lucky when it comes to
finding love
she's elizabeth hold and she has endured
four
first of all
[Laughter]
and ladies and gentlemen royce lopez and
marsh carted off the field
as they've smashed helmet to helmet
trying to catch the same
it is like that chocolate and peanut
butter thing it looks like katie seagal
and china were mushed together well
we're sitting from different angles yeah
you're right good point
it probably looks like china a little
more like oh i see katie stick all that
very katie
all right i see the kids
i don't like what you did to your
husband ma'am you let ron perlman kill
him
and then uh [ __ ] your son drove into
a truck or something and then a bunch of
asians were killed
yeah been out done over 200
uh debts i can't deal with the high
energy company jesus crow in the chat
says she looks like robot whitney
cummings
why wouldn't they make the robot young
looking man
i don't know why wouldn't they make
whitney cummings young looking why would
you make a middle-aged woman robot that
sounds horrible they're
like the least valuable creatures on the
planet
[Laughter]
and has been out and over 200
uh dates what she's been on 200 dates
i haven't gone too well but now she says
but says
all [ __ ] she's been on over 200 dates
and
rather get to the root causes of maybe
the fact that
she's the problem uh she's decided
to marry a dog rather than do
any sort of introspection and maybe a
look inside of herself
to see why maybe she's been kicked out
of a hundred and nine i'm sorry no wrong
hundred dates does she not ruthie she
has fined the one
found the one she's planning now to
marry the love of her life and he's
with her today her golden retriever okay
well that's a good boy
that was a good boy logan that is good
sad dog that has to [ __ ] that woman
yeah yeah her peanut butter budget must
be through the roof
through the roof and chilled
tell me about the love you have for
logan humphrey and uh and and and
logan has just looking at logan's face
there all right what do we think her
voice is going to be high and
shrill or deep and smokey
she looks like i haven't heard of her
she looks like a smoker smoker okay
that dog adores you for that there is
there is no doubt
yeah and i adore him um it's a year ago
today i rescued him
and uh the reason why i feel it's so
important to
you know celebrate this by doing this is
not only because i've been in lucky love
by
221 dates actually i'm counting
on that one um i rescued him a year ago
today um he has a very sad
past where he's now just turned six but
for the first four years he was locked
up in utility cupboard
chained
and when he came out he was rehomed and
now he's asking if he could please go
back to that lifestyle because this
is insufferable this is again man
they're pushing this [ __ ] somebody in
the chat actually had a good point too
guy goes on 200 dates unsuccessfully
he's an incel a woman goes on on 200
unsuccessful dates marry's a dog and
she's brave and stunning
you're right [ __ ] ridiculous man very
badly with dysfunctional families
and it was like we were meant to meet
because i just lost my other golden
retriever to spawn delighters who was a
gold retriever
so my son said get a doppelganger okay
you've said that what you've done for
him what has he done for you
he's safe he likes peanut butter off my
snatch
me and i've saved him and everyone i've
got a dog this is a mental illness by
the way
this we've taken pets to a mentally ill
level
yeah i'm a dog mom no you know you're a
pet owner you're a pet owner you're a
pet owner
um when i first got him and she said he
saved you and you've saved him because i
was a broken woman when uh
was past tense now she's she's fixed
now she's found the light broken woman
who's been on 221 dates
a broken woman who's now fixed and she's
marrying a dog
only eight but with his spondylitis his
legs just went and i was
absolutely devastated okay i get all
that but as regards human relationships
yeah and with men
in particular have you have you gone as
far to say you've given up
i love that she comes on the show when
she's talking more about the dog you're
not on the show because of the dog
you're rescued you're on the show
because
you married a dog yeah completely given
up i've
um hand on heart i've been on all those
websites from
oh i can't name these men i i would i
would give anything
to interview some of these men how long
this interview is a 10 minute long
interview i'd give anything
to i would rather i would give i would
give a half hour interview
to just one guy that's been on one of
these 200 dates
i want to peek in this brain yeah i want
to see
why these dates didn't go well because
that's that's
this woman is sick well anyway
there's so many muddy matches you know
farmers
millionaire match.com match.com
millionaire oh we're fit
it just slipped notice she went to
millionaire match then matched in
regular match
so she's a gold digger so this old no no
let's
break this down old
dried-up piece of rotten fruit that
broke off the tree a long time ago
thinks that she's she's not she's not
going to settle
why would she settle she deserves the
best because that's what she's been told
she does society is totally fancy she
deserves
only the best but
the reality of the situation is she's a
completely worthless
non-contributing member of society this
is
literally the mde the wall sketch
this is that sketch this is like the
sketch where they're like when they
bring on the three guys and one of them
is just a really good looking white guy
in a suit and they're like
what do you think any scott and he's
like well i mean she'd have to um
maybe if she works out a little bit and
gets a good job and really
works hard in a few years she would be
in a you know in a place where i might
be interested
it's just brutal but it's like that's
these women don't want to do that they
just think they deserve a hot guy in a
suit
like they think they deserve this young
you're a [ __ ] dime a dozen you're a
dime a dozen and by the way
most of you were overweight mentally ill
and highly damaged by whatever step
parent you had that had boundary issues
you're coming into this situation with a
lot of baggage be
grateful that anyone anyone
wants to spend time with you at this
point websites from
can i name some of them well anyway
there's
they said stop though they said don't
name it i have a feeling i know why this
woman's alone
what are the some of these aren't
american match sites
okay but liz but do you not get to the
stage where you have to ask yourself the
question
is it them or is it you it must be me i
mean i'm
okay well at least this guy's act hey
you know what
i'll be a little less harsh if she takes
a little personal responsibility
let's see yeah i don't know i mean have
you got particularly high standards do
you think
well no i tell you what i think no i
married a dog
how can my standards be really good
[Laughter]
what i think the problem is the older
men want the younger woman
yeah and the younger man wants the older
woman now i've got a son of 25.
men of that age are asking me out
seriously and i can't too that's not
right
so instead i'll do the same thing and
i'll marry my dog like again
all these things she's saying are crazy
but you married your dog this is what
happened
you had no problem dating somebody your
son's age the problem is is that people
your son's age
want to [ __ ] you yes occasionally not
marry you around
maybe you know hit you up at 2 a.m on a
saturday but
you you i guarantee you she has marched
down a road of a thousand
25 year old [ __ ] and none of them have
really
wanted to settle down because they're
25. you know what i mean so
that's the problem you could find a guy
your age the problem is
you don't want to [ __ ] a guy your age
you don't want to [ __ ] a guy
your age that's the problem because
you're a woman and you're entitled
and we live in a society that tells you
you deserve everything
you deserve everything queen and
anything less
then everything is [ __ ] and now
you're marrying a [ __ ] dog so how do
you feel about yourself
i want somebody a bit older than you yes
and then i also want someone that's sort
of
i mean i'll just run quickly through the
last thing that deciding thing and three
months ago i've been building up a
relationship with this guy
i did meet him through face but we we
became
you know he said he was separated
getting divorced and everything
i mean this one is so boring okay but
did you what you just said
i met him on facebook he said he was
getting separated
and getting divorced she [ __ ] the
married guy yeah
built up this relationship i hadn't
actually met him yes but
we were facetiming video chatting and
then
you were diddling yourself on skype we
know without putting it too fast
we were connecting and we were doing and
i started sort of getting through
was he lying basically well i cut to the
chase
we've got to be pleased for the love of
god you're not interesting again
the most interesting thing about you is
you married your dog rooty
on the video cool and honestly that's
not even that interesting it's not
oh and he said i love you elizabeth
and i said i love you alibi andy
and i and and then you know we were
you know on and then i hear in the
background
darling are you coming to bed his wife
walked in oh dear that was the final
story you just said that's it
okay so we get all that get all that we
have a lot of people that talk about
disaster but you knew he was married
right yeah she knew he said that um
you know i'm getting separated which is
what they all say when they're cheating
on their wives
that's what they all say have you tried
[ __ ] people that aren't 25 or married
this is really low energy too yeah she's
this woman's
i think i'm done with this i i can't
it's it's too it's just it's
it's just dumb she's not even smart
enough to like parlay this into
something interesting